gründeten Software Startup und RO
gründeten Software Startup dannh dieser
beiden Firmen erkläre ich euch einen der
wichtigsten Unterschiede den ihr bei der
Gründung eines Unternehmens beachtenut
ein Tool namens nindo der sich darum
kümmert die mittlerweile riesige
creatorzene im Überblick zu behalten wer
macht wie viel views wie viel Abonnenten
Wachstum Wert welche Skandale und so
weiter diese Informationen sind
vorrangig für Geschäftskunden wichtig
also Leute die z.B Werbung buchen wollen
el gründet perform all eine App die
Tipps und Hilfestellung im
Fitnessbereich gibtzepte Übungsanleitung
und so weiter die App ist ganz klar auf
die einzelne Person ausgelegt die eben
fit wer möch nindo richtet sich an
Business Kunden B2B und perform all
richtet sich an consumer B2C und warum
ist das jetzt wichtig früh zu wissen wer
Kunde deine Startup sein soll ist
essentiell damit du die Firma und das
Produkt auf diese Personengruppe
ausrichten kannst du wirst es am Ende eh
nicht allen recht machen können und mit
einigen wenigen Ausnahmen wie Apple oder
Amazon muss man sich relativ früh für
Business oder consumer entscheiden
danach im besten Fall die Zielgruppe
noch weiter runterbrechen und das
Produkt wirklich auf diese Person
ausrichten um ich mich aber trotz meiner
Reichweite sofort gegen ein Produkt für
den Supermarkt entschieden habe erfährst
du in diesem Video